foreign
from the rhythm of our heartbeats to The
Melody of our favorite song Sound is all
around us it has the power to make us
laugh cry jump out of our seats but have
you ever stopped to wonder how does
sound work
I'm rich Burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives four
experts delve into the intricate world
of sound from the nuances of frequency
and Timbre to the ways in which our
brains process and respond to Sonic
stimuli We Begin now with the
captivating world of the violin and the
physics that bring its music to life
[Music]
so where should we start
let's start where we usually start
with an a here's an A on a violin
[Music]
that's called a 440a and we're going to
talk about what that means in a bit now
instruments look different but they all
have something in common when an
instrument plays something is vibrating
causing a wave of pressure changes that
travel through the air and finally get
to your ear
the mathematicians have studied
vibrating objects extensively and their
work helps us understand the sounds
produced by all of the instruments in
the orchestra and eventually that'll
help us understand music
so when we hear something vibrating what
are we actually hearing when we play at
440a and here's it here it is again
[Music]
we might ask what frequencies are
produced
well we call it 440 Hertz and that's
after the 19th century German physicist
Heinrich Hertz
the higher the frequency the more times
the waves are vibrating per second and
in particular for a 440 Hertz the waves
are coming 440 times per second now you
might think that what's happening is the
string is just sort of going up and down
440 times per second
surprisingly it's a much more
complicated motion than that and there
are a lot of implications to them
with help from from Gordy in the audio
Booth I'm going to play an A and we're
going to see the Spectrum and we're
going to talk a little bit more about
the Spectrum later now what you're going
to see is that we have Peaks and the
Peaks come at different frequencies and
they have different heights so here
again is an a
foreign
[Music]
and what the spectrum is showing you is
that the string vibrates at many
different frequencies all at the same
time
it's 440 Hertz and then 880 Hertz 1320
these are all the multiples of 440. the
fundamental frequency is 440 and then we
just add that again and again
mathematically we talk about this as an
arithmetic sequence and the important
thing for us is that it's additive to
get from one to the next we're just
adding the fundamental frequency each
time
how is it that a string vibrates in so
many ways at the same time well we
actually have a demonstration to show
you that so imagine this vibrating
string blown up to the size of this jump
rope and when we vibrate the string the
mathematics is telling us that it
vibrates at many different frequencies
and we can see that on this string now
musically this is called the fundamental
and what you want to notice is that
there's a flat place in the middle
there's a place where the string is
exactly horizontal
we can actually get the string to
vibrate in a different mode and that
looks like this
mathematically we're talking about the
second harmonic musically we're talking
about the first overtone they're always
off by one when you describe that and
you'll notice that it has one node in
the middle there's a place where the
string isn't moving at all it also has
two flat places these are places where
the string is exactly horizontal
we can get a third mode vibrating here
's the third mode now there are two
places where the string isn't moving
those are the two nodes and now there
are three places where the string is
horizontal this is called the third
harmonic or it's called the second
overtone if you're talking to musicians
I think it's quite surprising that our
violin string is doing all of these
simultaneously listening to a single
string vibrating is like sitting in
front of an orchestra of jump ropes each
one is vibrating in one of these
particular modes that's why we talk
about it as a symphony in a single note
a single vibrating string is actually
many many different frequencies
if pitch perception and complex harmonic
tones was just a matter of the brain
detecting the lowest frequency in a
spectrum then pitch perception would be
simple
but a classic phenomenon in auditory
perception teaches us that things aren't
that simple
if we remove the fundamental frequency
of the clarinet tone or a trumpet tone
or a vowel what pitch do we hear
let's listen to the original clarinet
tone
[Music]
and the same tone without its
fundamental
foreign
[Music]
they have the same pitch the brain has
constructed the pitch from the
information in the remaining frequencies
this is called perception of the missing
fundamental and it's just one of the
many ways that we know that pitch is a
construct of the brain not a physical
fact about sound
research with other animals like monkeys
and songbirds suggest that they also
perceive the pitch of the missing
fundamental so this constructive nature
of pitch perception is likely to be very
ancient in evolution most of the melodic
musical instruments we're familiar with
like cellos guitars pianos and
saxophones and so on produce complex
harmonic tones why are we so attracted
to complex harmonic tones as musical
sounds
let me show you the spectrum of a human
voice saying the vowel e with a
fundamental frequency of 175 Hertz
it's a complex harmonic tone
now look at this spectrum of the vowel a
as in bat again with a fundamental of
175 Hertz
it's also a complex harmonic tone but
with a different spectral envelope which
is what makes it sound like a different
vowel
I think one reason we find musical
instruments with complex harmonic tones
so attractive is that they are
reminiscent of human vowel sounds our
brains have great interest in such
sounds because they're fundamental to
speech
in brain Imaging research that directly
compared processing of musical sounds
based on complex harmonic tones like
clarinet and flute sounds to human
syllables and vowels Amber lever and
Joseph rauschecker found a good deal of
overlap in regions responding to Musical
and vocal sounds in auditory regions of
the temporal lobe
have you ever wondered why your ears are
folded and grooved like they are it's
not for looks the shape serves a very
specific auditory function these folds
and grooves are perfectly designed for
capturing sound waves in the frequency
range of 500 to 4 000 Hertz Hertz are
just sound wave cycles per second
do you know what type of sounds in our
environment mostly happen within that
wavelength you guessed it human speech
when sound waves travel towards us they
get funneled from the external ear
called the pinna
inward to the eardrum
once the pinna funnels and amplifies the
speech sound waves they hit the eardrum
the vibrations there are mechanically
transduced into action potentials in the
cochlea which are then sent via
subcortical relay stations to A1 in the
temporal lobe the primary auditory
cortex also called A1 is located in the
superior temporal lobe along a stretch
of Cortex called heschel's gyrus
after a Sound reaches your ears A1 is
the first part of the neocortex that
processes those sounds
just like the visual cortex the cells in
A1 that process these sounds are highly
organized
because sounds are vibrations of air
molecules each one has a signature
frequency just like different
instruments in an orchestra have
different frequencies
A1 is organized such that certain cells
are dedicated to certain frequencies
the function of this topographical
organization is to ensure efficient and
accurate processing of sounds
this makes sense if you think about it
most of the cells that process a certain
frequency are located in the same area
so this allows for redundancy in signals
and the Brain loves redundancy
now phonemes are more complex than
single notes from an instrument and they
are processed in a network extending
Beyond A1 but the idea is roughly the
same
scientists believe that there are
dedicated and specialized cell networks
for individual features of the phonemes
in one's native language like ba and Pa
in English and oo and oo in Japanese
again the function of having specialized
cells for aspects of native speech
sounds is to help people process their
language quickly and accurately
we now believe that babies are born with
neural connections that allow them to
immediately start paying attention to
whatever sounds they may hear in their
particular language environment over the
first half year of life babies start to
expand the neural connections that are
involved in processing those native
speech sounds but then starting at six
months the brain starts to prune like
the trimming of a tree it prunes the
connections that are not involved in
processing native speech sounds while
strengthening the ones that are the end
result is that after one year
there is a reorganized auditory system
that has roughly the same number of
synaptic Connections in A1 but the
nature of those connections has been
radically transformed
at first the connections allowed the
baby to process all speech sounds pretty
well but after one year the neural
reorganization allows the infant to
process her native speech sounds
extremely well
Timbre is the quality of sound that
allows one to distinguish between two
notes of the same pitch and the same
loudness if you play a flute and a
violin that could play the same note and
the same loudness but you would still
know the difference between a flute and
a violin why do you know that difference
Timbre
here's a more formal definition if you
want to know a formal definition for any
musical term you turn to the Grove
dictionary of music and if you look up
in the Grove dictionary it says this
Timbre is and I quote a term describing
the tonal quality of a sound a clarinet
and an oboe sounding the same note at
the same loudness are said to produce
different timbres Timbre is a more
complex attribute than pitch or loudness
which can each be represented by a
one-dimensional scale high low for pitch
or loud soft for loudness the end of The
Grove dictionary of Music definition
includes the following line Timbre is
defined as the frequency spectrum of a
sound
Spectrum that's where the math comes in
that's what we saw last time we saw
graphs showing how much of each
vibration you heard how much of each
overtone that's the mathematical
connection to Timbre
I also want to give you what's a
negative definition of Timbre it comes
from the American national standards
Institute ANSI they Define Timbre as
everything that is not loudness pitch or
spatial perception
that's a different one spatial
perception neither of the other
definitions mentioned that spatial
perception is that you can tell where a
sound is coming from if I hear a sound
on my left side
how do I know it's on my left side
interestingly your brain does this
amazing calculation that Sound reaches
my left ear first it comes over and
reaches my right ear a little bit later
the reason I know that it's not two
sounds is that my brain decides that's
not two different sounds one before the
other instead my brain realizes that
it's one sound and because it hit my
left ear first it must be coming from
the left
I think that one reason Timbre is such a
powerful perceptual attribute in musical
sound is because of the crucial role it
played in mammalian hearing for hundreds
of millions of years long before humans
were on the scene
our early mammalian ancestors were
nocturnal creatures who must have relied
heavily on hearing for navigating their
world and identifying things in it
we know that one of the evolutionary
Innovations of mammals was having three
middle ear bones the malleus incus and
stapes instead of just one like reptiles
this probably gave early mammals
enhanced abilities to discriminate and
identify sounds very rapidly
this would have been important for
survival as nocturnal creatures they
needed good night hearing the ability to
identify objects by hearing alone
was that the sound of a delicious insect
they could eat or a small dinosaur
predator or a member of their own
species
these judgments depended on quick and
accurate processing of Timbre amplitude
or loudness of sound is measured in
terms of decibels
absolute threshold for hearing is zero
decibels with every 10 decibels
corresponding to a 10-fold increase in
sound
a whisper is about 25 decibels a normal
conversation is about 60 decibels and a
Subway or train is about 100 decibels
the outer ear channels sound waves
produced by air molecules through the
auditory canal causing the eardrum to
vibrate these vibrations then travel to
the inner ear which generates neural
signals that are sent to the brain
hearing at perhaps the most basic level
can alert us to potential danger the
rattle of a snake the Roar of a train
we also form fast impressions of people
based merely on the tone of their voice
people consistently perceive men with
low pitched voices as stronger and more
physically attractive
some research also suggests that lower
voices in men correspond with higher
levels of testosterone suggesting that
lower voices could also be a sign of
increased dominance and aggression these
traits historically have been
evolutionarily adaptive leading to such
preferences even today
another explanation is that lower voices
appear older which could be a sign of
experience and wisdom
in one study political scientists
recorded both male and female voices
saying the sentence I urge you to vote
for me this November and then digitally
alter the pitch of the recordings
creating a range from a low baritone to
a high soprano
400 people then listen to either the
male or the female voices and
consistently rated the deeper voices of
both male and female speakers as more
electable
in many animals low sounds indicate
aggression or dominance and higher
sounds indicate appeasement or deference
for example think of a dog growling
versus whining the low growl is an
aggressive signal the high wine is a
sign of begging for attention
these ideas were first explored by the
psychologist Eugene Morton in the 1970s
and elaborated by the linguist John
o'halla in the 1980s
think about how humans use their own
voices when trying to sound dominant and
confident versus different or uncertain
part of what makes Darth Vader sound so
menacing is the low resonant voice of
James Earl Jones
these psychological qualities of low
versus high pitches may stem from a
connection between body size and pitch
larger animals like lions tend to make
lower sounds than smaller animals like
house cats because they have larger
vocal Folds When Animals want to appear
aggressive or dominant they usually want
to seem bigger and making lower sounds
can convey an impression of a larger
size
when an animal wants to appear smaller
making higher sounds can convey an
impression of a smaller size
these ancient associations of high and
low pitch find their way into music
if you want to write a musical theme
that sounds menacing you're probably not
going to score it for Piccolo and if you
want to write music for a scene of a
child playing joyfully you're not going
to rely heavily on trombones
these decisions seem intuitive to us but
they're more than just convention they
probably reflect associations built up
over millions of years of evolution
[Music]
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandrium